today's episode is brought to you by the
US Army hello look at do honest trailer
commentaries the show where we talk
about the show of you hopefully just
watch which in this case is the honest
trailer for Avengers infinity war that's
the one yeah yeah I'm supposed to J
Gilbert episode Joestar Dan Merle who's
gonna hit you with the on stroke um
turns theme song hit it damn honest
McDonald's totally different so yeah if
you stick around to the end I think we
have some deleted scenes and stuff maybe
not this actually is a temp cut of the
Austral that we'll be talking about
today we're not done true fact we
actually pre tape these so the version
you see tomorrow which in this case is
today might be from yesterday which is a
case today for us now happening right
now guys this one this was quite a movie
and in fact we say that there's a lot of
movie and I stand by that yep stand by
what we say so much it is the most movie
it's so this was really hard because I
think the Russos do take in mind I think
fan response and they take in mind like
nitpicky plot in whole things like they
famously said they wanted honest trailer
proof Captain America Civil War I feel
like they kind of did the same for this
one this is very pretty tough pretty
tough flying hard to do a good movie
there's just so much crap going on
there's a lot of stuff any one holds
together more or less pretty well yeah
if you're a fan of the MCU it works and
if you're not then you don't know what
the hell is going on but also what are
you doing exactly they can you can jump
right in
it's strange because this isn't a movie
in the sense that it has the middle and
a finish but it is like the all-time
greatest season finale of a TV show yes
yeah yeah this is the Battle of
Blackwater yeah Pepa soda Game of
Thrones what are you doing if this is
your first Marvel movie it's not fair to
judge it on that it's like I want to see
lower the Rings return to the king be
like I didn't understand Aragorn
don't understand this so yeah I think
that this retroactive Lee makes me
dislike Ultron even more because it's
like oh you can balance all this craze
and all this crap going on and do a good
villain and whatever I mean well it's
it's also got like 30 minutes on any
other Marvel movie it's pretty yes
pretty long the viewing for the honest
trailer I came out liking this the first
time I saw it I don't even think I had
an opinion I just felt tired there were
things that I really liked and then I
went to bed yeah but yeah second time
around
because you've been serviced so hard
yeah my services it was he just saying
would you take a nap
my favorite is I went home I saw this I
was away the week that if any work came
out which is a great timing for both the
critic and someone who works for screen
junkie yeah and I will never forget the
the the the credits roll the lights come
back on and this lovely gentleman
because this was an Arkansas like stands
up and looks at the crowd and just says
who else is pissed he was not happy to
see so many heroes go but they'll be
back they'll be back we all know for
plot and meta reasons that they'll be
back set for drinks they're gonna be
like oh he used a body image shifter and
Thanos threw him off the cliff gamora's
fine yeah yeah oh I was just gonna say
like the quantum his Quantum's got
entangled and now he's Chris Jericho
yeah I'll be different yeah or shot
off-camera yes so I think long story
short this is actually really tough one
to write just because there's so much to
take on it's like yeah where do you even
begin because this is there's this movie
number 19 it is and and this one really
this isn't no Doctor Strange like you
have to be thinking of all the other
movies before this one before you can
watch this one so I like
it but I didn't really know what to do
with it and I think that goes for
everyone at this table that said let's
watch the honest truth yes and at the
end I'll give you my one nitpick that
didn't make it in
oh that over who that they did an honest
trailer proof this movie either the
following trailer is rated as for
spoilers you haven't seen this that's so
dumb we put spoiler alert for this one
but if you dull people yell I think
those people yes of Hollywood comes what
could be the best movie Marvel's ever
made but without a doubt is the most
movie it's certainly a most impressive
achievement so far yes all of this is in
one movie it'll definitely win the
popular Oscars infinity war into a new
era the MCU where after ten years of
having a streamline their plots so
normies would know what's happening for
me right into episode 98 part 1 of 2
without wasting a second on who anyone
is or why you should care because let's
face it you're either on this hype train
by now or the Winter Soldier using
Rocket Raccoon as a sidearm one means
freedom
they're both cyborgs rebelling against
their destructive program
why don't you listening to me it isn't
pausing do you guys have people in your
life
parents significant others etc who just
have no interest whatsoever in Marvel or
comic movies and you try to tell them
like no this one's good this is gonna be
fun I mean my grandmother I'm sure has
next to no but it's not so why don't
chat her up about like Drax yeah I
generally asked like how how was dinner
good you know my mom loves it cuz we
used to collect comics and cards when I
was a kid she would drive me around all
yes so she knows who most the people
aren't and she loved like I called her
she's like I watch it Logan my favorite
form of this was my my niece and nephew
really wanted to watch with the
Guardians movie with the holiday heroes
and Alec Baldwin's the German Santa and
yeah Chris Pine is Jack Frost and all
that what you ever seen that legend a
party and that's the Guardian yes
no no different audience yeah it's like
Santa and the Sandman and all of them
they have to fight the boogeyman and
it's a cute movie actually but my niece
and nephew really wanted to watch it and
just watching my dad sit in the back and
roast it well my watching my niece and
nephew like no it's the Sandman this is
what he does and you don't understand
yeah that's pretty great well it's tough
for this one it's I tried to talk my
wife into watching the ones that I think
are good and this one didn't have my
go-to crutch which is Paul Rudd's in it
watch this one but I couldn't get around
in fear three Chris's three Chris's is
probably not going to when are they
gonna make the ultimate draft move and
get pine oh yeah because he's in they
retained the team DC retained his rights
by keeping him in what happened to
mother like a Mama's gonna make him Adam
warlock or something they're gonna dig
him up in the ice Nick Fury what the
yeah all right part of that keep going
you listening to me
are you yawning all your favorite heroes
are here like Tony Stark the scientist
who finds out magic exists and takes it
in stride
he came here still a necklace from a
wizard but literally can't even win
another quippy guy with a goatee shows
up to go to store whose entire first
movie was completely undone we'd like to
express our profound gratitude decimated
zonda it takes it in stride but Captain
America who heroically accepts his
reduced role as a bigger role in the
next one right yeah when he dies well
early who could find vision probably
Steve Rogers black panther control the
screen time bears no one knew how big of
a deal he'd be I think the Russos
confirmed missing
better hit you right into space and die
then stay home and be in venom burn me
both kid but they're not alone because
all these other characters are also back
like Bruce Banner a man in desperate
need of a phase-three recap video he's a
metaphor fer there's a reptile
dysfunction is goofy right yes like a
band like like the Beatles Scarlet Witch
the x-man who's completed her Halle
Berry or could losing her I heard the
the the party line when this came out
was that like well she was she was high
in hiding so of course she would alter
the way that she spoke sure I don't buy
it
sure you know that was like part of her
guy alone with her boyfriend no I think
it's more like a reverse and American
goes to London for three weeks and comes
back calling everyone governing collar
trunks boots yeah it's brilliant
yeah but weren't they hiding out in like
Brussels these are my mates where were
they Scotland Scotland
someone well no I think you should maybe
like have vision come here supplies for
Nia no I think it's she was in Romania
or whatever forever and then lived in
America for three weeks and now she's
like hey y'all sweep with me it's not
Romania it's sokovia it's an art area
real country made up in my brain yes
sorry Accords yeah whole country was
destroyed barians me keep going Gomorrah
the emotional Center is also story and
the best she says like Leslie Nielsen's
strategy low-key slightly more dead than
the last two times the rest of the
Romanians pre James Gunn petition you're
the low key is Bruce Banner [ __ ] that's
why I can't reformed arts we smoked goat
cheese farmer but they're not
either because so many people in this
movie like Rhodey oak oh yeah waste of
tearing solution that vodka shot Wong
Sheree beaucoup
red skull Nick Fury oh hey Ben this is
Game of Thrones all again it is spawn
cast this at all right their name no her
name's for you for you Nick and Hawkeye
Snape
where's Clint Wow the only heroes
missing are the ones and all those
Netflix shows Kevin Feige hates me now
I'm iron fist
next time pause hey that would have been
a great way to a reinvigorate the
Netflix shows by having them all
disintegrate disintegrating yeah and
then be like there's been so many
opportunities to do a just a cutaway to
one of them I thought maybe they when
the thing was coming down and everyone's
running in the streets and they're
staring down the you know earth is
closed it's good word and they're flying
right maybe just maybe there might be
one no it's a little their absence is
very keep waiting for Daisy and may or
Coulson to just run by real quick and
just be like hey that's the ABC ones but
no no I thought like with Ultron with
like the Accords they're just gonna be a
montage of them like trying to get them
to sign the Accords and like look yeah
but no never no they they don't exist no
different multiverse maybe that'll be a
thing when they when you know ant-man or
Doctor Strange or whatever is facing
through villain at universes things like
in Netflix he's like oh god there's just
so much blood and bones breaking is
everyone so dour why is this guy doing
kung-fu and flip flops really stretching
on way too long these plot lines why are
we in the courtroom all the time 13
episodes
easily we're right in the episode
shut up the supply every time Danny ran
throws a kick they just use the reality
stone to be just like accordions out
immediately
anyways let's keep going and all those
Netflix shows Kevin Feige hates next
time iron fist next time or not for all
the characters crammed into the station
thrill as it centers around a buff ball
guy trying to grow his rock collection
knows he's been booking for the Infinity
stone so long because twice and after he
vowed in age of Ultron to do it himself
he waited like seven whole movies
including two that took place in space
and then boldly sent more of his kids to
do it for him you sir are a really bad
stepfather but dang what a great dad
I was not the idea that the internet was
I want to thank you both for uh just
believing believing in me for believing
in you sometimes people make dubious
claims so what was the weird reaction
when you're like why does Jose draft
have all this stuff about how sexy that
way down that was like most of the there
was like drool on the script like wipe
it clean that's like the most
interesting thing about baños to me is
that everyone wanted to have sex with
him I was completely unaware of this but
it literally took 30 seconds of research
for me to go you're right my negativity
in my doubt you were you are correct I
don't get it section and I was like we
could always put something back in about
how he's hot that's why I keep you
around Jose right at your finger on I
know what people want to have sex with
and that's the watch these movies catch
up to one of comics longest-running
traditions briefly killing people off to
Goose sales where with a single snap of
the fingers Disney erase the box of the
research thanks spider-man sexy
characters I look how much I've got a
copy of The Death of Superman to sell
you I mean it's just a bag I've been
conditioned with the are not one come on
no one how about the death of Tony Stark
did the Captain America how about the
war Nick Fury okay okay how about a copy
of infinity gone where the same thing
happens and they'll come back just fine
cool
cool so cool a story who throws a moon
honest attended some graphic graphics
we're still working yeah donation he was
a one eyed blonde for flying Purple
People beater thanks Jeff under Arbor
the Jumbo what pause I do want to talk
cuz everyone likes door Lords the
dumbest part of this movie is so dumb
why is he so dumb he is they're not
wrong he's grieving
well he's not dumb he's frustrating and
like being you know being well written
character doesn't mean that you do the
right thing all the time so look it was
very stupid insanely stupid but I
maintain the Doctor Strange could have
stopped him at any time yes
also he could have portal the other plot
hold that I found was like he why didn't
he portal Thanos's gauntlet off he could
have we felt like the other guy lost his
arm yeah yeah it's like setting up
they're like oh magicians can do that um
but he doesn't because he must have seen
in his you know he knows the one was the
one way in the one way it was for
star-lord do that stupid thing and I
will say Starla took a lot of crap it
isn't character cuz he literally did the
exact same thing in his last movie he's
all entranced and starry-eyed and Kurt
Russell's like I killed her and then it
goes stupid but he's emotional and I I
think that the Doctor Strange point is
right on because it's like he saw the
realities and one of those realities
might have been they temporarily went
they caught off his arm that get the
glove that he comes back with a giant
metal arm that makes him even stronger
he's got an even bigger army and then it
just gets worse hurry up spider-man or
something they cut off the glove and
spider-man grabs it and then you know
who knows what he would they may give
you with Sony and Thanos merges with the
symbiote ya know goku shows up yeah they
acquire all the all the eyepiece hold
them all and then we last action here
are themselves into the in the real
world the only one that can save us is
iron fist yep I was gonna say Charles
dance from Last Action Hero
oh yeah yeah which is an infinity stone
which is that final infinity step
confirmed oh if only keep going
- wall thanks for nothing beside the
Avengers tons protecting the century
like Forge a hologram for the king the
Justice League bestie game of stones
we're just gonna give him a pass for
pretending this was a standalone movie
yeah yeah we are
the final thing you see is Santos will
return yeah that's the literally the
last thing you see on in the film yeah
yeah well what didn't we show in the
trailer let's go right in the movie it's
so bright in there because I think I
don't want to say things that we
actually winning shot if we have them we
don't have we have some but maybe we'll
pull them into the next trailer share it
worst I don't know the next time yeah
we'll share them at a future try to find
a way to show you what we cut out of
this this story there's all coming
together at the last minute
last minute but we in a weird week yeah
what do we have do you guys remember
anything we said and cut oh mine it like
give my dog that it did not honest
trailer proof this but there's nowhere
to put it there is a a and if there's a
if there's an explanation then I would
love to hear the Russo brothers but they
established very clearly an ant-man that
Avengers HQ is an upstate genius Michael
Douglas literally says in upstate New
York they established the physical
location of the vendors HQ is upstate
New York and I went back and looked at
the side-by-side pictures of the two
buildings to prove it was the same place
and it is it's like Hudson River Valley
there's there's a there's like nice wait
until you pull on Justin long from
Galaxy Quest one of the Russos about
this this is the stupidest proof but it
is in this movie physically shown to be
within sight of Manhattan yeah you see
the skyline of Manhattan because they
need Tony needs to call the armor to get
the Spider Man in time for him to not
pass out from lack of oxygen
so avengers headquarters to have moved
from upstate New York yeah well we tried
to crack a final thing about Gerdes
inheriting the earth yeah I think we can
we can end with a an outro that we cut
cuz I don't know it just didn't feel
funny but it's that nerds we won
you know won and we became the bad guys
and this movie is the proof because now
we live in a world where everybody where
the mainstream where the entire global
populace knows and cares about Thanos
and Gomorrah and Iron Man and Captain
America and stuff like this and now
nerds are the ones being like it's not
that cool yeah yeah oh you like Marvel
movies yeah okay whatever it just seemed
like a yeah I only like Valiant Comics
that one with the Vin Diesel that's
coming up with the big dot on his chest
yeah I only like unpublished ninja back
issues yeah so I guess the bars been
raised to be a nerd you now have to hate
things that 10 years ago you would we
got everything we wanted yeah we got
everything we wanted to know still
mentioned be visit so Willy Wonka was
wrong you know what happened to the nerf
that got everything he ever wanted he
lived a twitter account
dachshund actress
that's a more depressing version walk on
the chocolate okay guys we clearly need
to keep working on this trailer we will
hopefully finish it by tomorrow which is
today which is yesterday which is right
now technically could be months from now
who knows we could finally so we might
all be dead but next week on this show
we'll have something very special
oh I hope sort of why we're in such a
crunch this week but man if we pull this
off you will say you did it again screen
jockeys you did it or you'll be saying
you'll be saying you did it again or
you'll be saying wow they really
over-promised and that's why you'll tune
back in I hope you come back next week
because we will are they today's episode
was brought to you by the u.s. army find
out more by clicking the link below
you